so it does seem as though we're getting
to the end stage of donald trump's
complete and total derangement over the
2020 election we are just what eight
weeks seven and a half weeks roughly
from the 2022 midterms and donald trump
is now demanding that he be made the
president immediately or that a new 2020
presidential election be held this is
obviously something only somebody who is
very sick could even think of demanding
donald trump of course posting this to
his pr platform truth social truth
essential uh a platform which is having
its fair share of trouble which we will
get to in a moment donald trump posting
yesterday and this is real this is
bottom of the barrel stuff guys quote so
now it comes out
conclusively that the fbi buried the
hunter biden laptop story before the
election knowing that if they didn't
trump would have easily won the 2020
presidential election this is massive
fraud and election interference at a
level never seen before in our capital c
country
remedy
declare the rightful winner trump means
make me president
or and this would be the minimal
solution declare the 2020 election
irreparably compromised and have a new
capital e election
immediately
he seems to be saying
that the fbi not helping him as he sees
it
is some kind of election fraud tampering
or interference and by the way the fbi
sort of did tip the scales for trump in
the first election that he won i mean
think back to 2016.
james comey already did a press
conference about the hillary email stuff
it was a closed subject
and then right before the election for
reasons that are still not clear james
comey comes out and does another press
conference about that very same
investigation even though there were not
charges forthcoming and hillary clinton
was not going to be charged with
anything
um
that is
the reality of the situation and think
how i i we're roughly it's funny we're
about 666 days since the presidential
election of 2020. it's just a
coincidence and i don't know if that's
tomorrow or the next day we're
roughly it will be soon
666 days since the 2020 presidential
election
and donald trump wants to either be
reinstated
um or wants a brand new election it says
likely that mike pillow
or eric trump are going to be put in the
oval office in the next two years as it
is trump is going to over 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines
exactly
remember this op-ed from november of
2020 it was written by mick mulvaney
remember mick mulvaney who for a while
was donald trump's chief of staff
and the subject was
if he loses
trump will concede gracefully he'll
fight hard to make sure the results are
fair
and in the end he'll accept the result
whatever it is that was mick mulvaney
writing in november of 2020 specifically
november 7th of 2020.
how humiliating is this how long is it
going to go and i know that we all joked
around we had sort of a good time even
though it was like laughing to avoid
crying saying
when it was
february of 2021 when it was
april of 2021 we joked around and we
said wow how long are they going to keep
doing this how
are they going to go all the way up to
the 2022 midterms talking about
reinstatement and trump continues to
talk about it and mike pillow continues
to talk about it and other hangers on
continue to talk about reinstatement
we are now getting to the november 22
midterm the question now is are they
going to keep talking about
reinstatement
beyond the november 22 midterm which
would be just another level altogether
it is wacky wacky stuff
and the next layer of trouble is that
the platform on which donald trump is
publishing these deranged tirades
uh
is in very serious trouble let's talk
about that next
one of our sponsors is xebiotix a
probiotic drink that breaks down the
byproduct of alcohol which is most
responsible for some of those rough
mornings if you drink a small bottle of
zebiotics before your first drink of
alcohol and then drink responsibly guys
please get a good night's sleep you can
enjoy the next day feeling refreshed and
ready to make the most of it sam cedar
swears by it here's how it works when
you drink a toxic byproduct of alcohol
builds up
in your unprepared gut
this byproduct causes you to feel
terrible the day after drinking zbiotics
produces an enzyme like the one your
liver uses to break down the byproduct
and zibiotix is fda compliant for safety
this is a product for responsible adults
who have just a few drinks
but they have plans tomorrow they want
to feel their best we all want to feel
our best if zebiotics doesn't work for
you you get your money back guys it's
that simple go to zbiotics.com
pacman and use the code pacman for 15
off your first order the link is down
below